موسكو لها مطالبه في شمال غرب البلاد
وبالتالي لا يمكن القبول باي تدخل تركي
الا في حاله تربيتها على الاقل في طريق
الام فور الخط الدولي الذي يمر بمنبج
ليربط بين شرق سوريا وغربيها روسيا تريد
ضمان ضروره فتحات وان يكون امنا ايضا
مبادله اخرى جبل الزاويه جنوبي ادلب حيث
تتمركز القوات التركيه في 16 قاعده من
سحاب الاكراد من المناطق الثلاث وربما
يكون ذلك سيناريو افضل حتى بالنسبه
للاكراد فالغارات الجويه لم تعد تقتصر على
الاهداف ضمن عمق الثلاثين كيلومترا بل
تجاوزتها لتشمل ايضا ما هو غير عسكري دير
الزور البعيده عن الحدود باكثر من 70 كيلو
مترا قصفها الطيران التركي ولي اول مره
وهناك اهداف اخرى ايضا اقتصاديه منشات
تكرير ان تشغلها قصد منطقتي ارملان الغنيه
بالنفط والتي توجد بالقرب منها قوات
امريكيه ورغم ذلك لا خوف امريكي على
مصالحها حقلا عمر وورد خارج المعادله وهما
ما يدور اهتمام واشنطن حولهما اذا هي
تداخلات معقده للقوه في المناطق التي يضع
صانع القرار التركيه عينه عليها والنفوذ
تجعل من التعقيد مضاعفا ما يتطلب استغلال
الطاقهات والتوظيف التناقدات حتى وان لم
تكن انقره بحاجه لضوء اخضر